hello Ian let's take a look at a time
frame for the future right now there's
going to be an energy mix a battle
between different kinds of energy
sources that will go on for 10 to 15
years right now we're going to have an
energy mix because no one white knight
can save modern society from the needs
of oil and coal let's face it
pound for pound oil and coal contain
more energy in a convenient form than
almost any other energy source now I
love solar but I'm a physicist and I
know that solar is not quite ready for
primetime yet
however the cost of solar goes down
every year Solar is being mass-produced
Solar is being given tax credits and
jump-starts by governments so we see the
cost of solar going down I suspect that
in about 10 years or so no one knows
precisely when the rising cost of fossil
fuels will intersect with the falling
cost of renewable technology and when
these two curves cross that'll be a sea
change at that point it will be
economical economical to go solar
however it's not going to happen anytime
soon now beyond that time frame when
we're talking about 2030 2040 then
fusion becomes an option at that point
Fusion is the power of the Sun the pop
probably the possibility of using
ordinary seawater to create unlimited
amounts of energy due to thermonuclear
reactions on the planet Earth now some
people are cynical about that they say
hey give me a break
we've been there we've heard the claims
every 20 years
they say that Fusion is 20 years from
now 20 years come and we're still no
closer to fusion there's a difference
this time we physicists think that we
have the technical problems licked in
California we have the largest laser
fusion facility at La saw at Livermore
National Laboratories and in France in
the year 2019 we expect to get the ITER
fusion reactor operational so it's is
projected that by 2030 24
by mid-century fusion becomes a viable
option and none too soon because with
the greenhouse effect we begin to
realize that the beginning of the
century could be quite dangerous we're
going to be putting large amounts of
carbon dioxide into the atmosphere
however by 10-15 years
solar becomes just as competitive as
fossil fuels in the marketplace and
beyond that fusion kicks in and fusion
is clean